yeah there's that's such a weird thing I
remember my my pastor at church he got
his like dream 57 Chevy and someone
keyed it at church at church
[Music]
what do you get
when you see one of these you know what
that is oh it's on my escalator
right yeah oh yeah okay yeah escalator
yeah yeah I agree it's actually from one
of those things at the airport where
like it helps move you along faster or
you're trying to get to your gate you
know there's like people oh the flat
escalators yeah the flat escalators
someone's hair what's different about
this picture though it's chipped there's
a hole yeah yep missing one yeah you see
that I was missing that thing somebody
get their foot someone got stuck in that
can I be racist what happens when you
get one of those should I be racist are
you now starting to be raised starting
now yeah
it's starting now that looks like a
Chinese one
is that racist not if it's your own kind
because it's broken it's broken and
they're still using it probably you're
close it's actually it's a it's a
Thailand one oh oh you guys want to see
what happens when you get one of these
no what happens no no can get ready for
this
oh my God what the [__] her leg got
stuck in there oh
whole leg went in that
and why is she plugging her nose just
she like oh my God like it smells so bad
with my bones being crushed up in this
[__] thing did her leg get chopped
off she lost her leg oh my God
she lost her leg wow little Ash
chip oh my God does she have a way bag
that looks like a way bag
I think that is what the the article is
mainly about the bag it's about how nice
of a bag it is
it has a laptop sleeve and it could
charge your phone it's a RFID blocker
it's product place that's your brand
it's the new [__] marketing tactic
dude as soon as she goes
and then someone throws an away bag
brought to you by away yeah oh my god
dude isn't that that's like a stuff of
nightmares yeah it is I think about that
all the time how can that little piece
Charlie your book it's you can Skip and
it goes all the way in it just keeps
going yeah so if you can get your foot
in there because it's so strong I mean I
got I got my [__] whole pant leg
stuck in my bicycle chain one time bro
isn't that scary I don't even know how
because you know like you should
probably contact her because you could
probably provide some comfort
[__] just fed into it and somehow my
[__] jeans got sucked into the whole
thing I'm like how the [__] you know
that uh that emergency push button they
don't have that or you just go bad and
then I mean I'm sure something kicked in
to the point where it didn't you know
that's where it stopped it stopped like
at her knee oh God because it got like
clogged yeah I think there is like a
thing that kicks in if it's like getting
resistance and you can't even Sue in
Thailand it's Chris
I'm not sure if you can can you no I
just believe outside of America there's
no such there's no lawyers or is her
fault too like she's like on was she on
her phone I mean like not the blame her
but like I was looking on her phone and
like I'm glad bark said it first but I
was thinking it like I love the ore yeah
was she not aware and then she was just
like this and her foot got stuck it was
like oh [__] I think it's probably that
it's weird because I really think like
when you read the articles about this it
almost sounds like they're trying to say
it's her fault
but I mean it was written by Asia's
probably the time who waits till the
last moment you know where that place is
it's where the scrubby scrub is right
who waits till their foot touches to pop
off dude
because all of us we jump at the last
point we hop right yeah like you look
down you're like oh sometimes my feet
aren't even touching because I'm [__]
holding myself up on the two black Road
also though too right because it is
they're just hovering it could carry
your weight so you're just like and
you're doing the yeah you're lifting
your legs up and then your wife's
yelling at you for being 39 and doing
that [__]
baby should be more like a kid I walk
around that [__] anyway because people
always just stand there yeah for real so
why am I gonna waste my time on that and
also too it's very abrupt when you're
like walking and then you go from the
platform to the actual stationary part
of the floor it is it's a big change so
what they're saying is that funny you
should mention the bag they're blaming
it half on the bag wow they say that
like her rolling suitcase was missing
two wheels therefore causing her to trip
over it at one point which made her foot
hit that exact spot yeah but why even
have a broken
situation it's definitely it could be
both no but the escalator like obviously
that is like accident Pro you should put
caution tape around it shut it down or
something
funny every single escalator in Las
Vegas is completely shut down at all
times
why is this one working yeah yeah with a
broken tooth
one third grader
yeah they find any reason to shut these
things off except for this one they just
turn it off right this one has a clear
defect and it's still running yeah it's
an anomaly but yeah apparently that's
what they're saying in the article is
that like she tripped over her bag oh
man and to lose her leg over that I
think that you probably if you trip over
your bed you probably shouldn't have
your leg gets still sucked in an
escalator like trip over it yeah that
shouldn't be you should be able to trip
on your back and then still safely get
on the escalator keep your leg at least
maybe that's crazy it sounds crazy
because it literally says she fell over
and her leg wedged into the conveyor
belt with the mechanism ripping through
muscle tendon and Bone oh my god
oh yeah so the other passengers did turn
the emergency switch off as as the
machine was like grinding her up what
kind of trauma nursing do you do when
you show up do you throw Vicodin in your
mouth immediately because like I think
you tell her to hold her ass
is somebody give it a heroin yeah who's
taking who was taking those pictures too
bro
um I think TMZ
right there man can you hold your nose
thank you yeah yeah what's up with the
nose holding I think that's just her
[__] trauma Lane response yeah hey
guess what I'm never walking on any of
those [__] things ever yeah it's over
I'll walk on the ground dude you know
walk on the ground walk on the ground
walk on the ground can we name that
video but then people still have freak
accidents just walking on the ground I
don't think that the floor opens up and
swallows your leg though yeah right
they're sinkholes
[Laughter]
things do just happen but this is one of
those things that you always fear would
but you're like nah
and then good problem I think we should
just always be careful wherever we go is
that good that's a hot take
we got phones I think you deserve to be
on your phone and not pay attention
while crossing the street I yeah I but
then is it doesn't things just happen
like you know like pictures of that we
just keep going back and forth we just
keep taking turns between but things
happen I wish Joe was at the hospital
just telling this lady sometimes things
happen that's okay have you guys had any
accidents at the airport or anything
like that no because in America you
double triple quadruple check you know
but like in other countries they have
the same rules it is kind of sad though
that like I've I've definitely like
messed around at the airport enough
where I deserve this to happen to me
yeah I've been on the baggage claim and
riding that thing yeah like that type of
stuff she's just walking like that sucks
that does suck but some people be clumsy
or maybe she wouldn't she wasn't walking
at all she was just standing yeah and
then the away bag got caught and then
she went oh yeah so her fault was the
fact that she wasn't walking yeah
do you think nah I'm not gonna no go
ahead you think she's stupid you think
this is in Phoenix Arizona yeah do you
think she's a little clumsy yep because
some people are accident prone though no
just say women are clumsy so you think
there's another photo for going I could
be I'm very accidental prone sometimes
like sometimes sometimes I I'll knock
the [__] the stove on and it'll turn
on by itself with your fanny pack
Nick is this one of those situations
where you're like hey on the bright side
at least there won't be another woman
driver
whoa you were gonna say that I don't
think I don't actually think that like
women are necessarily bad drivers but if
someone that cuts me off is a woman I'll
be like [__] women can't drive but
I'll also insert that with any anything
what if she's in a self-driving Tesla
the the self-driving Tesla stuff is a
little wonky sometimes oh it can't be
wonky and that's still it still it cuts
you off still I mean it's still her
fault because she selected self-driving
yeah yeah did you know that you can cut
off self-driving Teslas and they'll
always let you in
oh that's a little hack that's cool
because they're trying to be safe yeah
so like if you start edging in it'll
like let you oh that's cool you like
that finally a win for Nick dunno yeah
okay now I'm impressed have you seen the
compilations of people King Teslas why
do they do
grandmas too
slow that's [__] up why but the weird
thing is that I think I think there's
like a strange misconception going
around that people just equate every
model of Tesla to being like a hundred
thousand dollar car true because you
have to still buy like the extra ten
thousand dollar pack package were to be
self-driving yeah and then people just
look at it and have an animosity and go
like oh you rich [__] dude I had a chili
red Mini Cooper and somebody keyed it
and I'm like this thing's like 25 Grand
somebody stole it like true that one's
happening a lot that one's happened a
lot that's just the pettiness against
Teslas is really strange because some of
them are like literally 30 something
thousand dollars and it records too and
they probably hate Elon too it does
that is true yeah so if you're gonna key
any car why would you Tesla because
there's footage of you doing it that's
true that's the other thing you're gonna
get caught you're gonna get caught I
don't think they know that there was a
guy who just got caught Keen a guy's car
he's like a state senator or some [__]
he's keying the guy's car on camera wow
yeah yeah there's that's just a weird
thing I remember my my pastor at church
he got his like dream 57 Chevy and
someone keyed it at church at church I
think it was probably like a prisoner
that was like oh you don't get to have
[__] like this you're supposed to like
God doesn't want and then he announced
it on his sermon everyone went oh
dude keep someone's car is like a little
dick so [__] up it's a it's a what's
it called it's against the gentleman's
rule yeah right you don't you don't [__]
with a man's car well it's just so it's
just so petty too it's just like what
are you doing bro it's a it's such a
jealous ex-girlfriend move yeah dude
Nick's the kind of guy who says that and
JK vid but then if they cut him off he
follows them home and keeps their car
I walk by Bart's Car I'm like no no